[Musik]
in Frankfurt am Main im Stadtteil
Ginnheim machen Grundschulkinder und
ihre Eltern Woche für Woche ordentlich
Rabatt der Grund seit Anfang September
ist die Diesterwegschule in diesen
Containern untergebracht ein Pausenhof
für die Kinder gibt es aber nicht der
ist eine Baustelle deshalb finden die
pausene Grundschüler auf der Straße
statt die Eltern sind entsetzt das ist
Unmöglichkeit das geht gar nicht für die
Kinder man sieht es hinter mir LKWs die
dann zwischen den Kindern Durchfahren
einer absolut schlechte Situation für
die Kinder kann man so nicht machen
total wütend weil ich das einfach nicht
verstehen kann dass nach so langer Zeit
wo feststeht dass die Schule umzieht
dass hier fast nichts fertiggestellt ist
das letzte Schuljahr endet für die
Kinder in diesem Altbau hierher können
sie aber nicht zurückkehren weil das
Gebäude saniert werden muss der
Unterricht findet jetzt in diesen
Containern statt doch die ausweichschule
ist ein einziges pro Aquarium wo
eigentlich der Schulhof sein soll
berkeln Bauarbeiter und Bagger fahren
durch die Gegend auf dem Weg in die
Schule kommt den Kindern schon mal ein
Betonmischer entgegen auf die
haarsträubende und gefährliche Situation
weisen die Eltern immer wieder hin Demos
Telefonate Brief an die Stadtverwaltung
ohne Erfolg nix passiert
dir hat man den Umzug einer Grundschule
geplant eine Grundschule geplant und man
hat die Kinder vergessen das gerade die
kleinen hier so vergessen werden die
brauchen die Pausen die müssen ihr Hirn
bisschen lüften und ich finde es
unmöglich eine Schweinerei die Stadt
Frankfurt am Main sieht die Schuld nicht
bei sich sondern bei der allgemeinen
wirtschaftlichen Situation schriftlich
heißt es aufgrund der bekannten
insbesondere seit dem Frühjahr 2022
schwierigen Markt- und Liefersituation
konnte der Schulhof trotz entsprechender
Bemühungen nicht mehr rechtzeitig
fertiggestellt werden für die Eltern ist
das ganze einfach nur eine städtische
Fehlplanung es wurde uns versprochen
dass dieser kleine Abschnitt der Straße
gesperrt ist und als Schulhof genutzt
werden kann
seitdem ist immer noch nichts passiert
und es kann doch nicht sein dass wir als
Eltern hier Elterninitiativen Gründen
müssen demonstrieren müssen damit so
Basis Sachen wie ein Schulhof existieren
der Protest hat immerhin zu einem ersten
Erfolg geführt ab Dienstag will die
Stadt endlich die Straße für den Verkehr
sparen der Pausenhof so auf die
Verwaltung soll in den Herbstferien
fertig werden mal sehen ob das dieses
Mal klappt